[Music]
a little sort of bridge of normality
that's what porters are we're not giving
you drugs we're taking your procedure
talking about the weather
football whatever you know and and you
do strike up
a rapport with patients
no one has a greater run of the hospital
than the porters
i'm just going to sort the maps out
always behind the scenes moving patients
from one place to the next
the upside is when they go home but
during this
uh it's hard to put into words but they
may not be with us anymore see
recently jerry's work has taken a grim
turn
in the single month that we spent
filming at the royal free in central
london
130 people died in the hospital with
covid19
it's also the porter's job to take them
to the mortuary
for example when you saw me in the
mortuary there would have been names
that i knew
and i'm getting quite emotional talking
about it now actually
in recent days the influx of coveted
patients has decreased
this emergency covert ward we showed you
three weeks ago
adapted for the virus has now been
cleared out and cleaned
to make space for non-covered patients
allison who has a genetic condition
called polycystic liver disease
has waited more than 18 months for a
transplant
basically my liver is about three or
four times the size it should be
plus it's covered in cysts and they're
full of fluid
with covid and everything else there's
been a long
delay to my treatment so i'm really
hoping that today's the day
alison had to be dropped from the
waiting list during the first coveted
wave
and liver operations were completely
paused in january due to the pandemic
but finally the complex procedure can go
ahead
take some nice deep breaths
one of seven specialist liver centers in
the country this
is what the medics want to be getting
back to to be on that roller coaster of
waiting at home knowing that your liver
disease is getting worse
and that this is the only treatment
that's going to be life-changing
life-saving for her
it's it's i can't really imagine what
these patients are going to
the operation was a success but patients
like allison require intensive care for
several days
and in separate enclosed covid wards
intensive care is still
at double capacity patients requiring
round-the-clock treatment
with questions remaining over how to
keep resourcing it all
how do we decompress which is a
technical term for how do we reduce the
number of icu guides
how do we um give our staff a break
what's the answer and then how do we
make sure that all those patients who
need
surgery in particular but also other
services so so the answer unfortunately
that we're going to need a conversation
with the public
about how long patients are going to
have to wait for treatment this is going
to take
years not months to recover from one of
my colleagues is in here now
in intensive care with the virus
and it's really bad in this hospital
yes
it turns out jerry's colleague has just
come out of intensive care
and we're able to find him on another
ward i said no
i can't leave my beautiful
i ask god please god help me
and have you spoken to them respect your
children
i do i do but because sometimes
it it breaks my heart
it's i've been it's been a long time
i've not seen them so
talking on the phone with them it makes
me cry
huh yeah
it's okay
this latest wave is receding baker
is on the mend but the hospital is also
only just beginning it's road to
recovery
jason farrell sky news